haremos la misma suma que resolvimos el
vídeo anterior pero quiero desarrollar
todos estos números para que entendamos
realmente cómo funciona esto de llevar
así que el 5 está en el lugar de las
centenas representa entonces 500 el 3
está en el lugar de las decenas y
representa 30 el 6 está en el lugar de
las unidades y representa 6 de la misma
forma el 3 representa 300 está en el
lugar de las centenas el 9 representa el
90 porque está con las decenas y el 8
representa 8 porque está en las unidades
ahora lo podemos sumar empezaremos
sumando la columna más a la derecha
6 + 8 habíamos resuelto es igual a 14 14
es igual a 10 más 4
la parte que no es múltiplo de 10 la
podemos escribir debajo de la columna de
las unidades y la parte que si es
múltiplo de 10 la vamos a llevar a la
columna de las decenas y solo para
seguirle la pista y estar seguros de no
perderlo lohan notaremos arriba del 30
podemos sumar ahora las decenas 10 30
más 90 habíamos resuelto es 130 la parte
que no es múltiplo de 100 podemos
escribirla en la columna de las decenas
qué es
y la parte que es múltiplo de 100 la
ponemos en la columna de las centenas
nota que estamos llevando un 1 a la
columna de las centenas pero en realidad
estamos llevando 100 10 más 30 más 90 es
130 100 más 30 esto es igual a
+ 30
es todo lo que hemos hecho
ahora podemos sumar las centenas 100 más
500 más trescientos habíamos resuelto es
así que lo escribimos como 900 y
terminamos hallamos que 530 más seis más
390 más 8 es igual a 900 más treinta más
cuatro que es lo mismo que 934 espero
que ahora tenga más sentido llevar el
uno cada vez que lo hagas seis más ocho
es igual a catorce el uno representa un
diez y lo escribimos para no perderlo 10
más 30 más 90 es igual a 130 30 más 100
por último 100 500 más 300 es igual a